we got along pretty good great we got we
got along like like brothers kind of you
know except uh
we kind of had our bad moments too but
just like the movie and it's only
natural when you're you know with uh
with these guys for two three months
best of friends fight yeah yeah and they
have their good times too we were like
best of friends that fought and got
along great we had a lot of fun with it
we just lived in the 50s for the summer
and really got into it i wasn't that
scared
um
he fit in he was great because he was he
was always he was crazy it was funny
because he was like the most adventurous
one of us i'd say we would all like
tease him and stuff you know at first
and then like when he started like
fitting with us and we all got crazy and
he would just always go oh come on you
guys got to let me do this come on yeah
we got to do is get into this let's go
throw some
bottle stuff off the balcony that'd be
fun i was
a new yorker kid who had just started in
my first movie and they they all knew
each other from l.a and they had done
other movies so i was a newcomer
and i got to know them and they were
really nice i we were really good
buddies
[Music]
on the trestle scene i had to run and
like a train was breathing down our neck
so
well rob he was really explained about
things like
like you have to be scared at this
moment there's a vern this is the most
scariest point of his life and then i
just thought of something right off the
bat when i was a little kid i used to
have dreams that the closet would eat me
up
so i just thought of that hey
at least now we know when the next train
was due
chris uh
was a peacemaker he was a diplomat tried
to smooth things out between his friends
really frustrated with his life because
he was um trapped inside of this
reputation that that he was born with he
was like the bad kid in town and he
stole
and and he didn't want to you know he he
wanted to you know
climb above that and you know it finally
comes out in him and he's really
frustrated and he uh talks about it with
his friend party and gordy helps him out
no man seriously
am i weird
yeah but so what everybody's weird since
the scene where um
i'm telling gordy that he should be a
rider and he shouldn't listen to what
his dad says and we're walking on this
track and uh we had to keep a certain
distance from the camera and it was on a
dolly otherwise the focus would be out
so we did a lot of takes and that guy
kind of got frustrating but we did it
and it came out good we all kind of
helped each other because you know you
work off each other in a film like that
you have to work off each other when you
know it's four guys just through the
whole film just and that's what it's
about
it's you know i mean
we would go up to each other's rooms at
night and practice and stuff you know
we'd all go over to river's house we'd
do all the handshakes
and we would say all the you know slang
that they used back then in the 59s
man that's a plan and a half
[Music]
you